air france a décidé de se serrer la
ceinture d'un cran supplémentaire pour
sortir des turbulences qui ont plongé
cette compagnie dans un océan de pertes
air france a confirmé aujourd'hui
officiellement la suppression de 4000
emplois d'ici la fin 94 et l'abandon
d'une trentaine de liaisons reportage
yannick letranchant michel gènes hla
tous
la compagnie air france fait le ménage
ce n'est pas nouveau ça continue c'est
le troisième plan social depuis 1991
nous les jeunes on est inquiet parce que
bon si en effet les premiers touchés
ceux qui ont pas beaucoup d'ancienneté
ça a commencé il ya six mois par une
réduction d'une prime et puis voilà on
s'attendait elle continuité pour le
transport aérien et scully et notre
compagnie et sans doute encore plus
malade que toutes les autres
quatre mille nouvelles suppressions
d'emplois s'ajouteront donc aux 5000
déjà réalisés l'heure est plus que
jamais aux économies aux remèdes de
cheval
la compagnie se débarrassera de
certaines dessertes aériennes et vendra
aussi des parts détenues dans des
filiales comme les hôtels méridien
le transport aérien est toujours en
pleines turbulences la concurrence et
sauvage les avions ne sont pas toutes
remplies malgré les rabais
le déficit des cols 3 milliards 8 au
premier semestre pour air france riposte
celle où il faut mettre bout à bout les
flotte d'air france de british airways
lufthansa pour avoir une seule compagnie
américaine voilà pour la taille
savez vous que les compagnies d'asie en
découle un ferry les coûts salariaux
inférieurs de 50% parfois 60 % à la
moyenne des coûts salariaux européen
c'est ça la concurrence laquelle nous
avons à faire face c'est à cela qu'il
faut se préparer
nous négocierons pas ce plan nous allons
le combattre il n'est pas question pour
nous d'accepter dans les derniers on a
réussi à limiter les licenciements à la
compagnie par des grèves très dures et
cissé seul langage que comprend la
compagnie et le gouvernement
d'abord n'hésitera pas l'enjeu est
terrible pour air france une journée de
grève coûte 80 millions de francs